hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation an automated
robotic platform for 3d cell culture
processing of 64 independently
controlled bio reactors presented by
Robin Felder professor and associate
director of clinical chemistry and
toxicology University of Virginia School
of Medicine I'm Alexis Carla burns and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's lab rats is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen once there as many
of your questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located and the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits leave in welcoming dr. Felder I
will now turn the presentation over to
him hello today I'm going to talk about
an automated robotic platform for 3d
cell culture processing of 64
independently controlled bio reactors I
hope to explain why one would want to
actually build one of these kinds of
robotic systems and what in the medical
world is driving the need for increasing
numbers of relevant human cells so the
demand for cells for regenerative and
reparative medicine regenerative is
growing new organs and reparative is
repairing various parts of your body
ideally we would like
to have autologous cell therapy in other
words Bank some of yourselves and use
them on your own body so you reduce
systemic mythological reactions they're
of course highly biocompatible with your
body it'll eliminate disease
transmission which can happen when you
get cells from other sources and you
also get aesthetic matches and what I
mean by that is if you're trying to
match skin and various parts of your
body then you can match it perfectly
the alternative to autologous cell
therapy or act is heterologous cell
therapy and that is essentially getting
cells from others other human sources
again but they have to be bio banked so
you can try to match them as closely as
possible but there is no perfect match
unless we have an identical twin but the
problems with heterologous cell therapy
is essentially the opposite of
everything I told you about autologous
cell therapy and that you have
immunological reactions it's not
biokinetic compatible and get diseases
and the aesthetic matches are often poor
so cells as therapeutics most
therapeutic strategies require billions
of cells today we're used to growing
millions of cells in standard cell
culture laboratories also it's very
important to realize that frozen cells
need hours two days of incubation prior
to implantation so that they can get
strong enough to stand the the rigors of
the new their new location since you see
the picture on the right it shows the
various places that currently they are
replacing organs both by autologous and
heterologous donation they're certainly
growing corneas for placing in the eye
than many windpipe replacements when you
get windpipe damaged and they try to do
surgical methods on it they tend to
close off and make it difficult to
breathe so they now they take a
scaffolding put some of your up cells on
there grow up on the windpipe and
install it certainly bone-marrow
transplants we've known about heart
therapies where there's
taking stem cells and injecting them
directly into damaged or dead heart
tissue and replacing most of that liver
derived tissue can be used for some
literal replacement kidneys are well on
their way and bladders have been
installed in individuals now for almost
15 years with perfectly functioning
systems so and what's really exciting to
a skin instead of growing sheets of skin
which was the usual reparative medicine
approach now they grow suspended cells
and spray them on wounds much like a
painter would do in airbrush painting
and they can get very nice replacement
and rapid repair of damaged skin so what
we need is the ideal cell culture method
to support these brand-new medical
procedures what we have to do is take
advantage of the new three-dimensional
cell culture paradigms and I'll explain
that more in detail a few slides from
them what we want to do is provide some
morphology that mimics the invivo
counterpart that it has physiologic and
biochemical responses that are similar
or identical to in vivo responses we
also need a cell culture method that
will allow the comb culture of cells for
in-vitro organ models because organs are
made up of many different cell types we
want to automate that cell culture
process to provide not only convenience
and standardization but also to reach
levels of cell growth that would
probably not be easy to achieve using
standard manual methods you also want to
take the art out of cell culture because
those of us that do it know that it's
difficult to teach and once you've
somehow magically learned the art then
you can actually perform successful cell
culture so cells need an environment
that's very similar to the in vivo
living environment so we actually
control the pH the temperature the
oxygen the co2 humidity and even light
the surfaces cells grow on are very
important and they need to be biomimetic
you know there were they're similar to
the biology that they're used to seeing
we're feeling
should say the geometry should move from
a petri dish which is two-dimensional to
other kinds of 3d scaffolds and micro
carriers or little tiny particles you
also want to mimic stresses and that's
becoming more and more important to
understand that shear compression and
stretch are important clues that make
cells behave appropriately in the place
where they're located for example for
example heart cells and artery cells
feel a 60 Hertz compression going by
every time your heart beats your lung
stretches every time you breathe and if
you give the wrong clue to the wrong
cell they get confused you also want to
have appropriate disposables that can be
replaced such as pipette tips and
bioreactor vessels and the end-use
vessels if you're a lab automation
person you're one microplates of your
bio bank your cryo vials and if your
physician want therapy missiles so
hearing in examples of some of the
systems that are currently on the market
the wave bioreactor is essentially a big
bag that allows air and oxygen and co2
to permeate through the plastic that way
that bag is filled with a cell culture
solution that the cells can grow in the
cells are put on micro carriers which
are little tiny particles of various
sorts that allow them to attach and then
that whole thing is rocked in an
appropriate chamber to allow massive
expansion of cells the soul gem 310 from
the Brunswick is a small bioreactor that
controls all of the parameters in that
chamber electronically so it's
monitoring and adjusting and as the
cells grow and then the Corning came out
with spinner flasks which are
essentially a disposable version of
things you've just seen above and those
are simply suspend the cells using an
impeller looks like a propeller inside
of SLS an impeller
and that suspends the cells and keeps
them happy so culture has been automated
to various degrees over the last 20
years
Randall size of rationed
shows here's an aerial drawing of a
robotic system and in the center there's
a robot arm that's mimicking the human
arm but at least 7 degrees of freedom
and various hotels at the bottom that
look like those little stars and robot
can dishes off the hotel's put in
liquids and then put them in incubators
and then move them on to other processes
the front of our Institute as a cell
culture robot that I couldn't find much
about it was found I found it in popular
science but it's a quite sophisticated
fully automatic device that does cell
culture but these are two examples of
two-dimensional cell culture reproduced
using automation here's some more
continuation of that same topic
Sartorius Ted in biotech group has a
number 15 and those the upper picture
has these little bio reactors which are
on the right-hand side of that pair
those pair of pictures and those bio
reactors have individually controlled so
co2 oxygen and you can put different
media's in there put different cells in
there and each of those are placed in a
holder on an automated device that can
add and remove fluids the compact t
select T is a good example of automated
2d cell culture then that one is
essentially robot arm that handles
standard laboratory plastics and then
finally here's the cell culture
automation systems for stem cells
progenitor stem cells and in the left
hand picture you can see stacks of micro
plates and the device on the right is
the fully automated system but again
that's a automating 2d cell culture and
not much really needed which is 3d cell
culture the first example and probably
the only example I see in the literature
of 3d cell culture automation is this
one in fact I asked the author for a
picture of the whole robot and since
he's in Switzerland and it's taking a
while to get that picture but anyway the
issue is it's using dextran maleimide
hydrogels with bioactive components so
picture a very small blob of jell-o in
which cells can grow
on the surface or sorry on the
encapsulated inside inside that jello
and then you do all your automation and
grow the cells and then the hydrogel can
be passively dissolved or taken away so
you can get the cells back at the end of
the process so the question that might
be in your mind right now is why would
you want to do 3d cell culture over 2d
cell culture
well there's there are very this process
advantages and biological advantages
first with process advantages 3d cell
culture automation reduces labor
dramatically it's about an eighty five
percent reduction in labor but you can
monitor 3d processes continuously if is
automated
you can certainly increase yield per
batch or continuous or continuous
culture and it takes up a much smaller
footprint in this standard cell culture
laboratory the biological advantages are
better access to nutrients and oxygen if
you design your automation correctly the
graph on the right shows glucose on the
Left y axis and lactate or lactic acid
on the right y axis and time on the
bottom axis which is about four days or
five days what they did is grow cells in
a standard 2d environment and most cell
culture laboratories feed cells on
schedule but not on demand in other
words you don't know when the cells are
hungry you're just feeding on Monday
Wednesday Friday and then you give them
a real stretch Monday setting Sun day
because nobody works on the weekend so
you can see that cells room at a
conventional petri dish the red line
shows glucose dropping dramatically over
48 hours well actually 24 hours and it
goes from a healthy amount of glucose
down to zero and then you feed again and
you're back up to five millimolar and
then two days later it's down to zero
again
now when glucose is being utilized by
biologically your cells give off a nasty
by-product called lactic acid and that's
why runners have cramps and their
muscles does they get too much lactic
acid and their muscles well the same
thing with cells they get
it's bathed in their own lactic acid and
that can be very harmful to the cells so
that's not the ideal scenario - for
which to generate cells that are going
to mimic we say ones in your body so the
finishes of the automation is better
access to nutrients nitrogen better
morphology and physiology you can also
control stress so those important
stressors that point cells in certain
directions in terms of what to do when
you get more natural growth surfaces
there are several pictures of the
difference between the 2d cell culture
cells and what we're calling a perfused
cell culture which is they essentially
have media flowing constantly so it's
always special meeting event so that's
one way of automating your process it
tends to use a lot more media which can
be expensive but if you look at the
upper picture you've got much lower cell
volume there's a lack of little
finger-like projections called
microvilli and there's gaps in cell
junctions sounds like to talk to each
other and snuggle up tight but here
they're going to gaps between cells that
are grown in too deep in this profuse
cell culture approach you get taller
cells and you can actually see the
little finger-like projections if you
look closely those are the micro villi
expressing themselves and you get much
tighter junctions between the cells so
there are biological and process
advantages to 3d cell culture so we
developed technology in our lab here at
the University of Virginia to try to
take advantages of all of these
parameters that I've been telling you
about first we want to encode the gems
is there they're like little gems as far
as we're concerned growing really good
cells they're optically clear so you can
do microscopy on not only the surface on
the front of the cell but you can focus
back and look at the sides or the back
side of the cell they're non Austral
fluorescence so that you don't have
interference we follow those fluorescent
assays there's ferromagnetic in that
they're put in about 1% 1 or 2%
ferromagnetic particles picture like
iron filings that are protected with
silicon but they're in spurts -
throughout the micro carrier so you can
take a magnet and essentially manipulate
them that's handy if you're trying to
change the media that you pull all these
micro carriers to the bottom of the tube
and take out the spent media and put it
in fresh media take the magnet away and
you're back up and running again we also
have a agitation based suspension and so
these little micro carriers you put in a
special tube this gently agitated so
it's low shear but there is shear which
is important and you have better access
to nutrients it's also better suited for
automation and the cells always are
accessible and they're always in liquid
and it always in suspension unless
you're changing media so here are some
visual proof of the advantages on the
left side
kidney cells in 2d and you can see that
there's a cell looks like a pancake with
black spaces around it that's the gap
between that cell and the neighbor cell
then we have about 32 of those little
micro villi finger projections per
square micron and there it's not easy to
see in this picture if I take my word
for it there there on the right side is
3d so the cells are growing each one of
those red blobs with our blue Center as
a cell growing together and on top of
this seaweed seaweed jello is called
alginate and you can see two kinds of
best features first the sort of lists
are looking projection on the left hand
picture and the end of the 3d notice
that's a something we haven't seen in
any Cell on the 2d and that's a natural
phenomenon for these cells to have those
kind of lists of projections and then on
the right you have very tightly
interdigitating cells which it also
doesn't happen into E and notice that
the microvilli density jumps from 32 to
360 for Mike and their life per square
micron and that's more like what happens
in the body we also have improved
epithelial cell electrolyte transport
but I don't want to go into too much
detail about that today
so here's a gorgeous picture of that
cell under scanning electron microscopy
you see the bead where the cells just
sort of put it off and put it on top of
this picture but if you take one of
those cells and there's no men really
close you can see what looks like a
forest of microvilli but more important
you see these things that looked like
antennae sticking up there well each
cell has one really long it's
essentially a sensor it's out there
weaving around saying okay do we need
four fewer or more of these microvilli
for the process that we're being asked
to do we've never seen those in a cell
culture environment before so you can
also through automation and using these
kinds of micro carriers you can automate
many of the standard cell manipulation
protocols that we use a science and
laboratory such as electroporation or
zapping and with electric sparks to put
molecules inside them we can dispense
them we can transfect them which is
putting other molecules in then we can
also freeze them or cryopreserve them
and throw them out in about a 95 percent
survival rate which is far superior than
about for sixty percent survival rate if
you do standard cryopreservation of
cells and not on these micro carriers so
the benefits of automated automating
this process is you're emulating in vivo
environments you get very high cell
yields from very small amounts of black
space it's scalable from individual
researchers to large-scale production so
it's the same process whether you're
growing one tube of it or doing hundreds
and thousands of tubes it significantly
reduces labor consumables and compared
costs and it eliminates contamination we
can take cells that are very difficult
to grow on plastic petri dishes and grow
them easily we can automate virtually
the entire cell culturing process we can
also provide real-time monitor and your
feedback control so you know essentially
comforted by the fact that the cells are
growing well and happy so when you're
doing your experiments you're more
likely to have successes and as
physicians are replacing cells in the
human body you have a better survival
rate so
years CAD drawing of our current
prototype cell culture system we're just
trying to demonstrate to everybody that
this is indeed possible and so that
means fit in a standard elevator in any
building that supports laboratories so
it can be delivered plug in and it's
ready to go question you might have in
your mind right now is why what's the
relation for building an automated cell
culture system within my own laboratory
well briefly explained that we're very
interested in how the human kidney and
its regulation of the salt balance in
your body controls blood pressure and
ultimately if you don't get it right you
have strokes blindness kidney failure
and heart attacks and especially if you
don't get your salt balance right you
can ascend reduce your life expectancy
by 20 years so we're very interested in
this process but getting people's
kidneys getting fresh kidneys for doing
research are very difficult because
there are such high demand for
transplantation
so we developed a method to take living
cells out of the human urine and
cultivate on these 3d alginate micro
carriers and you can essentially get a
large number of cells and a large
diversity of cells that we can study so
we can study not only one cell in your
personal kidney but all of the cells
that are excreted which is virtually the
entire kidney so we're moving our
research program from studying just one
cell or one cell type to studying the
entire population of cells from an
entire population of individuals so
that's why I put this table in here we
have we have collected and are
collecting cells from individuals at
birth all the way through death we're
also collecting a wider and wider race
representative races we're doing males
and females and so at the end of our
collection period we'll have thousands
of cells from thousands of individuals
and asks questions that will give us
answers that are highly biologically
relevant because no two people are
identical but there is some sort of
baseline
human existence so we can find that
likely baseline so you can features of
this particular robot to solve these
more challenging problems no single
human or even a team of people can grow
64 random-access 3d cell cultures
simultaneously it's just never been done
before so we have that capability within
this robotic system it's all in an
environment environments with the
control enclosure there's minimal human
intervention sterile environment with
positive internal pressure to keep any
bugs from getting in there we can
automatically sample media so we can
test it we can feed the cells when
they're hungry you can culture the cells
directly from frozen vials and we can
dispense them into plates for scientists
like 96 or 384 well plates in order to
do experiments and ultimately we can use
it to grow cells for their place in
human body plates so it has certainly
the temperature and the co2 and o2
concentrations controls many any
commuters processes don't control oxygen
only co2 that we control oxygen by
injecting nitrogen and so we can lower
oxygen concentration which is very
important to mimic what's going on in
your body we have all the air going into
the system has HEPA clean so there are
no viruses or anything larger then we
have certain heart disposables that we
developed not only the micro carriers
but special bioreactor tubes called
levee tubes because we levitate the gems
and then the thing that does the
levitating is a wiggler a bio wiggler we
have places to store media and we
preheat the media before it gets to be
cells so they don't get a cold shot and
tomorrow robotic gantry so we do a lot
of work one robotic system and lots and
lots of liquid hand pumps so here spent
a little bit of the inside systems here
we have the robot gantry liquid handling
robot there dead centers the bio reactor
array with 64 independent cultures we
have a pH sensor over on the right and
the robot will sent them into those
tubes and drop a drop on the pH sensor
so we can record progress
sells eating the glucose lower left we
have a refrigerator with a large
quantity of media various types of
mingling without waited to just one at a
time with into four different cell
culture meetings and then below the
right is waste collection and electron
only electronic control systems the
environmental controls monitored by
percent volume with a resolution of
about 0.01 percent and we have that
integrating and valve controlling co2
and nitrogen taste to essentially keep
that co2 and to where you need is the
temperature control is with a resolution
of hundreds of degrees that the pair of
high-throughput circulating heater unit
so there is no difference anywhere in
the box temperature gradients and that's
enclosed by a pressurized HEPA
filtration system to keep it clean so
here's some examples of how tightly
control our variables sounds are very
forgiving cuz cells and your fingertips
and very there's not in your tongue in
your toes don't have a lot of oxygen
because by the time it gets down there
is mostly used up so they're used to
lots of oxygen and then no matter it's
about twenty three percent nitrogen
excellent so their cells are can be
exposed to a wide range but we're going
to control these parameters a lot
tighter themselves really need it
so here it's since co2 at five percent
is typical with about two 2.75%
air variation in that temperature at 37
degrees about three percent change so
managed through a PID controller and the
setpoint
can be customized to best suit the cell
populations being cultured so this is
the system it's essentially the Jim
micro carrier the levy to bioreactor
automated wiggler and the off the shelf
tea that he can camera on the robot with
two arms and this whole system is
probably about five to ten times less
expensive
correctly on the market yet it gives you
more biologically relevant information
with you today and so there's something
unique about the levee tube is that it
essentially does the washing machine
motion where there was a first circle
right and a full circle left it just
keeps doing that as long as you want to
they can do it really fast we're really
slowly and inside that two more little
veins of plastic and those are designed
very specifically and patented to
levitate those of the micro carrier so
they maintain an even cloud throughout
the - that's a certainly difficult thing
to do is maintaining an even suspension
for weeks months and maybe even years
and here's the one module of a wiggler
which we have four of these over 64
separate modules then through that so
this is the media storage and preheating
and that's important because the media
is kept for four degrees Celsius and we
wanted at 37 when it touches the cells
so it goes through the box sitting on
top of this refrigerator and it warms it
up to 37 degrees prior to dispensing so
it's a it's an on-demand kind of thing
and we like certainly can have four
media containers but if you have greater
needs let's say you wanted to grow cells
for a year and leave it autonomous
without any human intervention then you
would essentially Park this robot next
to a cold room and have very large tanks
of media so you can just continuously it
means new cell cultures and that's going
to be probably the case when they're
glowing large organs and having them
bioprinting them and having themselves
organized you're going to need this kind
of larger scale system and to monitor we
can monitor not only the cell density
and that's important because you want to
know when the cells are ready to be used
for the next process but that's the
optimal moment of confluence you can
also control doubling time so you could
change the temperature you know a cell
culture robot and slow them down if for
some reason you didn't want
to get confluence before the time is due
if somebody's coming in to get their
skin replaced you can time the amount of
confluence of cells for their arrival at
their appointment and have plenty to do
the skin replacement and so we I spent
pH sensor is just pictured there and we
simply take their very time you drop
putting it on there at solid state and
then measures and then rinses and then
you're ready to the next but fortunately
cell culture is a very slow process it
takes a week or two to get the cells
ready to be taken out of the system
unless you're trying to grow billions of
cells and they take a month and so there
you've got plenty of time for the robot
to do all these measurement kinds of
things it's not minute to many it's
really hour to hour if you have
large-scale needs I mean we took some
human kidney cells and we grew them for
nine months in our system and generated
an enormous number of cells and they
maintained their steady phenotype
through the entire nine nine month
period I figure a scientist at the bench
and you're interested in having the same
kind of data week after week month after
month when you're doing a series of
experiments this is the way to do it is
to work large numbers and draw from that
same pool every time you need cells for
your experiment and you won't have the
variability that happens going from
batch to batch to batch and splitting
yourselves each time you can even do
experiments from these micro carriers
directly from the freezer you thaw out
with my carriers with the cells on there
ninety-five percent survival rate and
pipette them directly into your essay so
that's even a more convenient way to do
experiments using this automated 3d
approach so finally this is where we're
going you know turning near future
almost completely autonomous in our
automated cell culture robot which is
the one in the middle there we already
are fully automated in terms are
screening using cells to screen for new
mr. cell physiology the pipetting robot
is actually married to a
spectrofluorometer so i can do all the
measurements without any human
intervention what we're really talking
about doing is on the far left is
automating przemek storage of cells so
that automated cell culture robot can
grow up large quantities it can hand it
off to the freezer and it can put it
away and then when the robots when you
said the guy over on the right there is
in need of cells to do experiments
cryogenic robot can hand it to the
automated cell culture robot to get the
ready handing it off to the automation
and the experiments get done so this
essentially automates everything that
happens than a standard biochemistry
from the suitable laboratory so finally
I'd like to acknowledge our team which
they're not all listed here but this is
the current principal level of PhDs in
Cheddar and I won't go through each one
of them but there I do what a highlight
we've had new students capstone project
participants where teams of students
come in and dive in and work on one
subsystem and get credit for it so it's
nice for them to get exposure to
laboratory automation so thank you for
your time today
thank you dr. Felder for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop down box
located on the far left your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is where in the regenerative
and reparative medicine process will
robots most likely be deployed okay the
answer to that question is the robots
are needed particularly in preparing
cells for their introduction on or
inside the human recipient and very few
people are aware of the fact that
just can't take cell shipped across the
country and open the package and inject
the cells have to be coddled from that
fairly bumpy ride to the hospital so
every single hospital will need a robot
system similar to ours and we designed
it for that purpose to be handling lots
of different patient specimens making
sure they're adequately happy and stable
and then you know the physician would
get a note on their cell phone saying
okay the cells are now suitable for
injection into your humans participant
so that's the probably the most widely
needed area in the future for 3d cell
culture automation but certainly any
pharmaceutical laboratory you need them
particularly in doing all their drug
screening and it's important the
pharmaceutical companies understand that
with this kind of system you can do
population biology so you can take a
drug talk a potentially good drug and
find out if it will work for a wide
range of people as opposed to a one cell
line so it answers a lot of questions
early on in the process rather abandon
ship percy and dr. Felder it looks like
we have time for one more question
it appears that all the cells in this
robotic system will be at the same
temperature
do you anticipate a scenario where
different temperatures would need to be
simultaneously on different cultures and
how would you accomplish this task if it
was necessary that's a very good
question because that's actually
something we are anticipating for the
research market and particularly having
a cell culture system that can not only
grow cells from animals and humans but
also plant cells the question is why
would you want to go plant cells in the
same place you're growing human cells
well we would like to check the
effective plant nutrition on cell growth
that's the perfect way to do it all
within one system so yes we have to have
bio reactors individually temperature
control but right now we said let's
start simple and let's focus on all
temperatures I would say 99.99% of cell
culture done that there's at 37 degrees
because that's where our body
temperature is tender yeah I would like
to once again thank dr. Felder for his
info for his presentation I would also
like to thank glabrous for meeting
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I would like to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2018 you will receive
an email from labyrinth lighting you
know when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye